[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
>> That's when you know all these
questions. Avery asking folks and my
funds at 3%.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Obviously any
>> It's all good though. We appreciate
y'all stopping by and everything, you
know. Y'all be cool. Be safe for today.
>> Always. You too. Likewise.
>> Hey, how are you?
>> Oh, I'm pretty good. What's your name?
>> Save.
>> Yousef. Nice to meet you.
>> Nice to meet you. When you know the
answers to all these questions, why are
you asking for folks to discuss
>> for uh for these?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh well, one, everybody has a different
answer for the why you're a Muslim and
then who wrote the Quran? Actually, that
one actually is a mystery.
>> No, no, we want to make sure that they
have a right answer.
>> Everybody has an answer. You going to
educate them?
>> Sorry.
>> You're going to educate them.
>> Of course. Yes.
>> Let's see.
>> That's what we're here for, brother.
>> All right. So, pick any questions.
>> I don't need to pick a question. I know
the answers and I know you.
>> Yes. Kids even know the three.
>> But I've seen your your your videos
online. So I know people much more
versed than myself. They have given you
the answers to these.
>> No, they haven't. That's why we still
have
>> Which one don't you have the answer?
>> Okay. So So like for example, for who
wrote the Quran?
>> Yeah. Who wrote the Quran?
>> Nobody knows that.
>> Zab and the committee that he put
together under the first
>> he he had it compiled. Yes. But who who
else wrote it? Cuz remember he had to
collect it, right? So who wrote who
wrote those original scripts that he had
to collect? I can give you the list of
all of the the original writers of the
Quran. It's not in the Quran. The Quran
the Quran doesn't have introductory
notes by the author or the anonymous
author like for example Luke who will
come out and say I saw others writing
this. So I felt it also uh good to write
those down. So the Quran, the authors,
the hadith, all Islamic writing are kept
separate,
>> right?
>> Because you answer you as the question.
>> Make sure that okay.
>> No, no, you asked the question. I'm
answering your question. Right. So so
the Islamic literature is very clear
when it comes to the documentation of
the Quran. It is only what was revealed
to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. And he then instructed the the
writers of the Quran to write it down.
Now there's a list of those authorized
writers. We know who they are.
>> We know who Zimabid went to go and
collect the writings of the Quran from.
>> Okay.
>> And then the half is the memorizers of
the Quran who then he validated all of
that work.
>> The compilation of the Quran wasn't just
from the writings or the collections on
the writings,
>> right? Some people memorized it and
stuff. Yeah. So, so what our question
would be is like what you just said that
that list of people who Zade collected
the Quran from those scripts from that
material and then he compile that he
compiled it like who are these people?
>> Those are the writers of the Quran. I
can give you the list if you want. Do
you want the names? I know you've been
given the names.
>> I actually have never to this day I've
never been given that. Honestly,
>> I'll get you the video where there's
multiple people that's given you that.
>> They haven't. Nobody has given me that,
brother. I'm not lying to you. If
somebody has, I would have been like,
"Okay." You know, cuz I know of Zade. I
know of Zade. I know what he did.
>> Yeah.
>> But I don't know who specifically he
collected those uh those texts from.
Is there a hadith that uh says this or
would this like be more so
>> history? Books of history.
>> Books of history.
>> Yeah. The hadith is as you know it's
just the saying of the prophet. So the
books of history is collected in S. And
it's not just the S of the Prophet
Muhammad but it's the S of Islam because
you find S of the Khifs after the
prophet Muhammad's pass.
>> How would you know? cuz um like there's
a there's a Sierra by Iban Ashak, right?
That that's kind of popular, but I hear
that there's some controversy with that
one. How do you know which like Sira I
guess to you can go by? Like fully.
>> That's the beauty of Islam is because
we've got many writers of of Sira and
they tell us their methodology
>> unlike the gospels where the methodology
the author remains unknown
>> for the four main.
>> What do you mean? M
>> who wrote Matthew?
>> Matthew did.
>> There's no Christian scholar that agrees
with you on that.
>> Every single one.
>> Show me one
>> in the earliest ones.
>> Show me one.
>> In thee.
>> Papus and Erenus were amongst the first
Christian scholars, church fathers.
>> And they say Matthew or Matthew.
>> They say this as being the first people
to attribute it to Matthew.
>> But my friend, they don't claim
authorship by Matthew. We're the first
ones. Show me papers.
>> They were the first ones and and I know
you had this debate with a couple of
guys. The Har Krishna are in a very
joyful.
>> No, these are uh I think Hindus or
something like that. Harrishna Krishna.
>> Uh
>> yeah, servant Krishna.
>> My train of thought.
>> Uh you said you're talking about the
first ones to
your names. They were the first ones to
attribute the disciple Matthew to the
authorship of the gospel scripture that
we know today
>> that we have recorded. Yes.
>> So, so you ask for Christian but there's
a difference in terms of saying he's the
author. Authorship being attributed to
Matthew is different from saying Matthew
is the author.
>> How? What's the difference?
If if you attribute authorship to
Matthew,
>> you know this.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And I know you know this. Yeah.
>> Then I'm attributing this authorship of
this pamphlet to you. Someone 150 years
after you die finds this. There's no
attribution to you,
>> but they say without evidence that this
was written by me as an example, but
there's nothing linking the document,
the pamphlet to me.
>> Papus doesn't come 150 years after that.
He was he was a companion of his
>> companion of who? Uh uh I don't I don't
I I forget exactly who Papus was under.
Um but him we got Ignatius who was under
John, Polycarp under John, Irenaeus who
was under Polycarp. Um I'm sorry under
Ignatius who knew Polycarp. So you have
these all of the church fathers agreed
with these people that they was born in
60 CE and died 130 AD.
>> Yeah. So he's not he didn't come 100
some years after the after the apostles.
He lived in their time. He he lived up
to a 130 AD.
>> Yes. And so born in 60 AD and he was
still in their lifetime. And he was a
follower of who you said baby.
>> I I don't I don't remember exactly.
Let's see what
>> Let's just check on on what Google tells
us.
>> Baby is church father.
[Music]
He's an author who lived in 161. He
wrote the exposition of the sayings of
the Lord.
He wrote in Greek.
[Music]
>> I could probably text my friend and ask
cuz he he knows this stuff.
>> Oh yeah, it's good. Very little is known
about him apart from what can be
iterated from his own writings. He
described as an ancient man who was a
hearer of John
>> and a companion of Polycar.
>> There you I call disciple.
>> So,
>> so a hearer of John and follower of
Polycar, disciple of Polycar. So, so he
knew John.
>> John who?
>> John the apostle. He knew John and then
also was a companion of Polycar. So,
he's he's a he's a contemporary and he's
saying that Matthew wrote a go wrote his
gospel. Um all all of the early church
fathers say that they're all in
consensus that you know Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John wrote their gospels.
>> No, they not. didn't know this.
>> Uh, every last one of them are in
consensus in the all the church fathers
in consensus.
>> I I know um
>> what's this uh guy's name?
>> But Bart Arman's close friend.
>> Bart Arman. Oh, Bruce Mezer.
>> Bruce Mezer.
>> Uh Dan McLaren and Berman himself.
They're all in agreement that Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John are anonymous
authors.
>> No. No. Okay. So, no, you don't know
what they mean by anonymous. When they
say anonymous, they mean that the uh
they didn't put their names in the
original work. So, that's what like if
you're talking about textual criticism,
that's what anonymous authorship is. Not
that they didn't know who wrote it.
>> That's not what an
>> Ruth Mezer affirms that that Matthew Mu
John wrote the gospel.
>> Let's see that.
>> Bartman doesn't agree. That's where they
disagree with each other.
>> Let's see that. Bruce Mezer.
Okay. Sure.
of the gospel.
[Music]
We obviously can't go to Perman for
that.
[Music]
Shall we try this one?
I guess so. wayoflife.org.
Probably have to skim through this, huh?
Yeah, I don't have any of the the
political text or books of these guys
now.
>> yada yada yada.
[Music]
That's just kind of talking about his
career.
Just kind of giving a biography of the
guy. Let's see. Let's go
that this possibility remains that
evidence available to us today means
that it was unrepresentative of the
readings that Mexico presently claimed
that some portions of the original
scriptures might have been unfinished or
lost if copies had been made of the
original whether Mark was corrupted by
writing. Okay, that's the ending of
Mark. Short or long? Dicated
at Matthew incorporated in his oil
genealogy.
Okay, so he's talking about the
>> it's more this more so like a biography
of heavens.
>> But um but yeah, he he thinks that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John wrote
wrote our gospels. All the all the
church fathers, if you look at all the
early church fathers, they're all in
consensus on who they are.
>> No, you know, you know that's not true.
>> It is true. There's not one that that
disagrees. Okay, I I'm going to go on
your channel and I'll post some links
where there's varying dis varying levels
of inconsistency and blatant
disagreement.
>> There's not one among the church fathers
on who authored Matthew, Michael, and
John. Not one.
>> Well, I'm I just told you now Bruce
Mezer and these modern scholars use
those early church fathers sources to
say that there was an
>> Bruce Mezer doesn't say that.
>> I'm going to show you. I just don't have
the documents here. But in one of the
lectures, uh
>> all right. So, so with that, so let's I
guess put that to the side then. So then
if if we're talking about authorship,
right? Um now going back to the Quran
with what Zade collected.
>> Yeah.
>> I I haven't seen I haven't seen this.
>> The collection of what Zade collected
was the secondary source.
>> Say that again.
>> What Zade collected was a secondary
source material.
>> Secondary source material.
>> Yes. The primary source material was the
memorization of the Quran from the fats
from the memorizers of Quran.
>> Oo that's tough.
>> That's why I'll tell you why that's the
case because his committee
he had a criteria for them to be on that
committee. Do you know why that was?
>> Who who who chose this committee? And
>> Zade Zed was commissioned to put
together the the the Quran. He was given
a council and he assembled he was in
charge of assembling the committee. Do
you know what was what?
>> I don't remember him assembling a
committee. You
>> I I can show you.
>> I I just remember him going out and
collecting the Quran from people who had
different parchments, different people
who memorized certain verses. Not
everybody memorized certain verses. He
went to certain people. Like there was
this one chapter and verse that he only
found with one person. Like other people
didn't have it.
Even so on Wikipedia I don't even have
to go to Islamic sources.
Zade was given the task of collecting
the Quran verses from all over the head
of the committee including Ube which
performed this task. The number of
people in this community in some sources
are around 35 whereas in others it's
around 75
>> regarding but what's what's the okay can
let's go to the do they have a source
for this let's see number four yeah
click that
[Music]
>> what is this
>> you mind if I hold this
>> encyclopedia of Islam Muslim source, but
>> it it's confirming the Muslim narrative
that Zade was in charge of committing. I
leave you with this.
>> I would I would agree that Z was in
charge of collecting the Quran. But to
say that what he was collecting were
secondary sources as to where the
memorizers were the primary, I I don't
know if I was I would agree with that.
>> I'll tell you what, you may not agree
with it, but this is a historical fact
and I'll I'll get someone who's more
knowledgeable than me to give you the
information. I know in the past they may
have
>> but one of his key criteria for people
being put on this committee was what?
>> Was who?
>> Was what? What? Do you know what that
criteria was?
>> No.
>> The person who was put on the committee
had to have been one of the commissioned
writers of Quran who were the writers of
the Quran for the prophet or they were
memorizers of the Quran.
>> Okay. So you couldn't just be some Tom
Pikah Harry who said, "I've got a
parchment with some writing of the Quran
on here. You had to have been a
memorizer of the Quran or a script
writer."
>> And so so I I hear you, but I I would
need I would need to You're good. I
would need to see that. You know what
I'm saying? I would need to see the
Hadith source that says that Zed Bavid,
you know, very critically picked who he
was collecting the Quran from. And he
was very selective with that and careful
with that. I would need to see that. I
guess like methodology.
>> Yeah, I would need to see the
methodology, you know. I I' I've
personally never seen that in
>> Yeah. God logic.
>> God logic.
>> God logic. Yes, sir.
>> For you the there's there's there's very
detailed
>> analysis of the compilation. Okay.
>> But they come back to this point. Zade
was head of the committee. It was a
thorough process of compiling the Quran
and getting it with the memorizers of
the Quran.
>> So let me ask you There was unanimous
agreement on the end product which he
compiled which remained with the wife
with hops right with Hapsa and was
later.
>> So the important thing is then what
happened after that right cuz so we see
a problem is fixed and solved right a
lot of the memorizers died off in the
battle of Yamama. So Abu Bakr has Zade
collect the Quran so it doesn't get lost
cuz people are dying in battle.
>> No he doesn't have them collect the
Quran. He has them proliferate the Quran
based on the standard text which
>> mean what do you mean by proliferate?
That's a big word for me.
>> You have an original pamphlet. Now
instead of making unauthored copies of
that pamphlet, you go back to the
original pamphlet.
>> They didn't have that yet.
>> They had the original. It was with
Havsa.
>> No, no, no, no. So they they the the the
Havsa manuscript is what they collected
and then then they gave that when they
passed it that Umar had it and then Umar
gave it to his daughter. That's uh
yeah
>> let's let's go this
>> look we can pull this up so
>> during the time of man Khalif so here's
the first compilation right yes
>> the first compilation is formalizing
the Quran what do we mean by formalizing
the Quran it's taking the disparate
copies of past partial components of the
Quran verses and surah that were on a
variety of documents plus the memorizers
of the Quran and putting it in the
standard codeex as we know today right
excuse me the second standardization
which I'm referring to is during the
reign of the khalifman
where Islam had spread the battle of
yama had taken place he was asked to
head up a committee for the second time
a group of companions headed by
who has been stationed in Iraq came to
and urged him save the Muslim um before
they found the Quran
>> because now people were taking Quran
from memorizers, from other learned
people writing their own scripts and
they were differing in what they were
writing down.
>> So let me ask you this then. So when it
cames to cuz this is this is the first
uh one we're talking about with Abu
Bakr.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Um a lot of people are dying in
the battle of Yamama and so so that the
Quran is not lost they have it compiled
for the first time.
>> No.
>> Yes.
Sent to me from
he said
Yeah, this was the first complication.
Yeah.
>> So, so he does this so to to basically
preserve the Quran so it doesn't get
lost, right? And so then so Z does it um
>> and then it gets that so what they
collected becomes the standard
manuscript that keeps getting passed
down.
>> What they collected does not become the
standard manuscript.
>> Yes, it does. Hold on. Let's see if it's
in here.
>> Listen, the artifacts that he collected
were written on leather, written on
parchment, written on bone, and came
from the memorizers. those parchments.
>> Look, look, look. It's right here. It's
right here. So, look right at the
bottom. So, then the complete
manuscripts of the Quran.
>> The word is there in brackets.
>> Can you see that copy?
>> Yes.
>> So, they made a standard text.
>> Do you agree with that? So, it wasn't
what was collected.
>> No, it the the the standard text is what
was collected.
>> It was the contents of what was
collected.
>> So, so you understand the difference?
>> Let's let's Yeah, let's try to break it
down. Let's say for example pieces of
Quran is written on all of these
pamphlets.
>> Zade goes around and collects all of
these pamphlets,
>> right?
>> He doesn't take each pamphlet,
>> put it put in a binder and say this is
the Quran.
>> He takes the contents plus what the
memorizers have creates a new authorized
script based on these artifacts.
>> Okay. Yes, I agree.
>> These artifacts do not become that
standard script codeex which was what he
compiled.
>> Right. Right. Right. I I see what you're
saying. Yeah. the contents that's in
these scripts they put in file is copied
and put into an authorized
>> got and then this authorized codeex gets
passed down to Hafsa right okay we're on
the same page then okay so it gets
passed down to Hapsa and then in Uman's
time there's another issue right as you
said there's people that have other
manuscripts of the Quran they're
differing and about to fight over it and
stuff like that so they you know they
say man save us and fix this so what he
does is is that he has everybody turn in
their manuscripts turn in their copies
whether the whole Qurans or you know
manuscripts he burns them all and he he
takes the hops uh
>> he doesn't do that he asks that they
destroy it you didn't have people coming
to a big bonfire and throwing their
Qurans in right his leaders in the field
there was no calling of books I'm just
being accurate with it
>> but it it says he ordered that everybody
turn in their Quran
>> yes but he didn't come back to him to
man
>> so where did it go
>> in wherever they were they got rid of
their nonauthorized texts and started
using the authorized text.
>> All right. So, hold on. Let's let's
let's check this out really quick.
So, let's go over to the very next one.
So, this is the one.
>> Yeah.
>> And then let's see here. So, Ukman sent
a message to Habsa saying, "Send us the
manuscripts of the Quran so that we may
compile the Quranic materials in perfect
copies." Yes.
>> And return the manuscripts to you. Habsa
sent it to UMA.
>> All right. Um um man then ordered
Zenabid Abdullah uh the second yada yada
yada to make perfect copies right make
the manuscripts in perfect
>> and send it out into the empire.
>> Right. Right. All right. He says in case
you disagree with Zabad or on any point
in the Quran then write it in the
dialect of the Quresh.
>> Yes.
>> The Quran was revealed in their tongue.
They did so and when they had written
many copies man returned the original
manuscripts to Havsa. Um man sent to
every Muslim province one copy of what
they had copied and ordered that all the
other Quranic materials whether written
in fragmentaryary
>> he destroyed where they are. He didn't
ask them back.
>> I understand what you're saying. Yeah.
So so he had them he ordered them to
burn the manuscripts that they have
except the manuscripts that's now being
sent to you.
>> Here's the authorized version. You no
longer need these unauthorized versions.
>> Yes. Yes. Okay. So now with that being
said, we have obviously a central
control of the manuscripts of the Quran,
the standard manuscript. And one can if
they're on the outside looking in, they
can look at this and say, "Hm, this is a
bit suspicious." If there's one central
power controlling the manuscripts,
>> I would understand that coming from a
Christian background.
>> I would understand that because you're
looking at it with your Christian
Christian lens.
>> Not even Christian.
>> No, no. I look, let's be frank. You you
you
You you you could look at it from a from
I mean there's only two or three real
religions that talk about
historical preservation of their
scriptures is the Abrahamic faiths.
>> The Hindus don't even claim that their
their scriptures are historically
>> uh sound.
>> So when we talk about this, you can only
look at it from those three lenses. And
you being a Christian, me being a
Muslim, you're going to take it. I I'm
not defending Islam. I'm looking what
the facts are. The process is
meticulously documented.
>> Your guys process, the Christian process
has recently been come uncovered. What
do I mean recently become uncovered?
>> We're talking about since the advent of
of textual criticism really where people
went into the study of the Bible and the
gospels,
>> right? And what we've seen is a initial
decentralized
proliferation of different gospels, not
a Bible as in the Quran. Right? Later
then the church comes together and
decides one of the church fathers is one
of the first ones to name the authorized
copies that should be in the New
Testament. that is then later over
various ecumenical councils adopted over
time as the reading of the New Testament
as we know it today.
>> But that are you talking about the whole
New Testament or are you talking about
the gospel?
>> The bulk of it. No, no, I'm not talking
about the Bible. I'm talking about what
we know today as the New Testament.
Okay.
>> As as scripture that the Christians
believe in
>> was not a book called the New Testament
in the time of Jesus nor his disciples.
>> Correct.
>> Right. the letters of Paul, the gospels,
the the the other texts are named later
on as being the revelation and over time
becomes codified and we've got the first
example of that complete collection in
the form of the Codexus and the Codex
Vaticanis later on right the point I'm
making is very early on we knew
the the manuscript and recital extent of
the Quran in the early Christian era. We
didn't know that.
>> Whoa.
>> What what I'm saying is you didn't know
that and you'll agree with me because
what you have in the New Testament today
is a filtered is is the outcome of a
process of filtration. There was many
books which was decided that these
aren't revelation. you call them today
the apocrypha many gospels
>> they were they were never considered uh
uh to in the Christian church at all
never
>> in the Christian church but the early
Christians considered them
>> there these are the early the churches
that are the early Christians they never
considered them
>> uh you know
>> you're talking you're talking about
gnostic heretics
>> gnostic heritics they classified as
gnostic heretics today they were they
were there back then they were just
followers of Jesus back then
>> no they wasn't
>> when when was the church
>> the church the church the church look
>> an evolution this no so look I I I I can
agree that you have a like a there's
development of doctrine and ideas and
concepts that happens in that happens
all the time that even that's even in
Islam right but to say that oh because
there's other people that claim to be
followers of Christ who the apostles and
the church fathers um unanimously
um um disregarded as heretics ics
because they're going against the
teachings of the apostles and their
teachings of Jesus and the prophets.
They're out.
>> That's the point that I'm making. How do
you know what the teachings of the
apostles and and Jesus were? It's from
largely the textual
>> uh the textual
the textual preserve
>> because we we have a we have a chain we
have a cons. Yes, we have a consistent
chain of authorship among the church
fathers that unanimously recognize
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John as
scripture. The church is dead, but I
don't have something to prove it to you.
So, I'm not going to argue that. Let's
say that that is the case. So, you're
claiming authorship. There's a there's a
consistent, as you put it, claim of
authorship,
>> consistent tradition.
>> You don't attribute Yeah. It's a it's
it's I like the word you put. It's an
attribution of authorship. It's a
consistent attribution of authorship of
authorship since the first church father
makes that known.
>> But the but all of them knew this. No,
not all of them knew this. There was an
initial
>> Why is there no disagreement?
>> Because the the it was adopted from the
first one who made the claim.
>> No, it's adopted from the from the
people who know the apostles who know
them.
>> One person made that.
>> No, not one person. All of them.
Irenaeus if I'm not mistaken was the
first person to attribute
these the names to these gospels and
claim them to be divine
>> and then Arane is telling but but Aronya
is telling you who before him was
claiming these gospels and you're
getting these quotes right from these
people who knew these guys this is a a
chain of it's a chain of authorship here
>> I I I'll I'll I'll
leave that point aside because I don't
have the the textual evidence to say
you're wrong or not on that.
>> Fair enough. Um,
>> but like what what I'm saying is that to
lay this out, we we we know what the
gospels were and they were historically
accepted by the church. When it comes to
the text of the Quran,
there's there's these differences where
the companions are fighting over what
the Quran is.
>> No, they're not.
>> Yeah. Even they beat up Ibman had Ib
Massud beat up because okay let me just
show you that he uh he disagreed with
like the current reading for example.
>> So like for example if you were to go to
like uh
chapter 92:3 of the Quran Ib Massud had
a different reading.
and and and the prophets will have
different read the companions will have
different readings of the Quran based on
the just like there are those who
disagreed on certain hadith having
either not heard them or not validated
themselves like you and I having this
conversation now the early Muslims were
the same and and God bless their spirit
and their pure hearts they would not
accept something unless it was verified
by others and once it was verified they
moved on from that point okay
So let me go ahead and try to pull this
up for us really quick. Right here it
is. Okay. So Sai Bkari 4944 narrated
Ibrahim. The companions of Abdullah bin
Masoud came to Abu Dha uh and before
they arrived at his home he looked for
them and found them. Then he asked them
who among you can recite the Quran as
Abdullah recites it. They replied, "All
of Excuse me." They replied, "All of
us." He asked, "Who among you knows it
by heart?" They pointed at Alma. Then he
asked Alcha, "How did you hear Abdullah
bin Massud reciting Surah Al?" Right.
The night Alama recited, "By the male
and the female." Abu Ada said, "I
testify that I heard the prophet
reciting it likewise, but these people
want me to recite it, and by him who
created male and female, but by Allah, I
will not follow them." So, what we see
here is we obviously there's a different
reading, but it's the response to the
different reading that shows that the
he's he's disagreeing with the other
reading. You get what I'm saying?
>> You you're reading it, but you're not
reading for understanding in this
hadith. I'll explain to you what you're
break what you're missing in this study.
>> Abu Da is coming to who?
>> Uh the people who follow Abdullah Masoud
>> Abdulah Masoud is a acclaimed scholar.
Yes.
>> One of the highest scholars. So he's
speaking to the students of Abdullahb
Mas.
>> That's right.
>> And what he's doing is a very important
principle in Islam. Go to the people of
knowledge and verify.
>> Yes.
>> What Abu Dha is doing is going to the
people of knowledge. The people of
knowledge are confirming his
understanding of the Quran.
>> Yes,
>> he
is saying I have other people with me
who are disputing what you and I know to
be true. We are the scholarly class.
>> Yes,
>> these people are differing with what we
saying. You and I know we are correct. I
will not follow the uninformed. I will
stick with what is the informed.
>> Right. I agree.
>> Yes. So, but that's so that speaks to
the preservation of the Quran because
the memorization
corrects this because they he's saying
there's a problem saying listen what
he's saying there's the end at the end
part there are others here with me who
have another reading
>> I will not follow their miss
>> and he doesn't name them in this
>> right he doesn't name them but they're
they're the mistaken group
>> they're the mistaken group
>> and he's going with the preserved
reading and what he knows to be correct
and this is what that the principles of
a hadith is
>> whatever is linked via a valid narration
and chain to the prophet is what we
follow. We don't follow people whom we
don't know who are anonymous and we
cannot attribute their narrating back to
the prophet via a valid way.
>> Okay. I understand everything that you
just said. Now let me show you why this
is a problem.
>> Tell me. The problem is is that when
we're recognizing that that other group
Yeah. that Abu Dhab was with is the
incorrect group, they're following the
incorrect reading.
>> Yes.
>> That's the reading that exists in the
Quran you read today.
>> No, it's not.
>> It is. If you look, if Hold on. Can you
hand me uh look, it's in chapter 92:3.
In chapter 92:3, it reads exactly how
that Abra said is the how the incorrect
group reads it.
Okay. Chapter 92:3.
Um,
okay.
>> Almost there.
I'm going to need your help.
Okay.
So,
verse verse three. All right. By the
creation of the male and female. Right.
Or do you read Arabic, Isa?
>> I read Arabic. Okay.
>> But I I I I cannot translate from
Arabic.
>> No worries.
>> We can read. Yeah, they can.
[Music]
Yeah. And then there's the translation
on there by the creation of the male and
female.
>> Right. That that's the one that Abu Dha
said is wrong.
>> Listen. Yeah.
>> Right. So he says um so Abu uh they said
by the male and female. Right. Abu Dar
said, "Yeah, that's how the prophet
recited it. These people want me to
recite it and by him who created the
male and the female, but by Allah, I
won't follow them." So the Quran we have
today has the incorrect reading while
the preserved one was lost. You get what
I'm saying?
>> This is verse one, verse two, verse
three. Mhm.
>> Get the corn. Are you not eating
over there?
I just want the one verse.
>> Yeah, Google Translate is also created
in the
>> What is the hadith number?
>> Uh it's Sai Bukari
>> 4944.
Somebody taught on that.
>> Just give me one second.
>> One eternity later.
So what are you looking at now?
>> I just
>> I don't know.
>> I see.
>> You got to look at this hadith in terms
of
its veracity. Now what I'm seeing here
is there's multiple hadith
being recorded by Bkari in 4944, the one
you showed me,
>> by Muslim
and by
>> the problem that we have is that all of
these hadith are referring to different
verses of that same soul. They're not
referring to that verse that you
mentioned that's not the verse in 4944.
So here in 4944
Abdullahbas comes to the companions he
asks them and to ask them
recited by the male and the female.
Right? So it's the surah the verse
concerning the male the creation of the
male and female and whether it's by the
male and female or by the creator of the
male and female. In Abu Muslim he comes
and he asks them the same essential
story is citing this verse but here
talking when the night covers so it's a
different verse of the same surah
>> right and it's not about the one it's
about when the night covers and the
males and the females upon this he said
so it's about the covering it's a
different part of the surah then interi
comes he says by the night as it
envelops so it's a ga it's talking about
the night and it's not talking about the
creator of the male and female.
>> Wait, wait. Can I Can we look at this
one real quick? Cuz both of them
mentioned the chapter of the night.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But you can come I can
show you the verses.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So he's talking about different
verses of that same chapter.
>> I understand. Let me just read this
really quick. This is interesting. So
they pointed out to me and said yes. He
said how did you hear a little recite by
the night as it envelops? He said I said
I heard him recite whatever that is.
>> Can you you understand? So you can hear
the the story is the same. Mhm.
>> This chapter of the Quran is the same
>> but the compilers of the hadith are
saying that the narrator or the
different narrators because these are
different hadith captured by different
compilers and the topic of disagreement
because he's still disagreeing with the
people of Syria that he has with him but
he's come to the the the scholars of to
verify he's reading but he's talking
about different verses of the same
chapter
>> and again here's one by Imam Ahmed and
they point to me and said did You hear
Abdullah recite by the night as
enveloped. So you've got three of the
four hadith talking about the night
enveloping and not the male and the
female.
>> Mhm.
>> So you can see it's about different
parts of this the this the surah.
>> Yeah. So will we say that uh Bkari is
has a an authentic hadith or
>> look the hadith is not going back to the
prophet. The hadith is going and and
this is the the art and the science of
hadith. when you've got a hadith that is
talking about a specific incident. So we
can see this is the same incident. It's
the same main person coming to the same
secondary group of people talking about
the same issue. But the detail which
matters here is slightly different right
now of the four actually five narrators
Bkari is the only one that brings up the
issue of the creator in the middle. The
other ones are talking about another
loss
>> the night,
>> right?
>> And and
>> I'm not a hadith scholar, but what
typically happens is that they look at
all of the uh and that's why I said I
wanted to look at the soundness of the
hadith that Bkari captured because even
sometimes in the book of Bkari, there's
not always a sound hadith. Bkari is a
compiler. He tried to compile as sound
as he could, but some hadith are still
weak in his book. You look at all of the
different
>> compilers and you look at the strength
of it and you say hey based on the
strength of this based on the chain of
the narration based on the validity that
this one is talking about this topic or
these three are talking about this topic
and only one is talking about the other
topic then the topic must have or the
actual conversation must have been about
this. So there's a process that they
will go through to look at what is the
I'm not saying that's the case here, but
I'm giving you some insight in terms of
how critical scholarship looks at a
hadith.
>> I understand what you're saying. Yeah.
From from what I've heard, uh I've never
heard that it was a a weak hadith. That
would be I'm not saying it's a weak.
>> Yeah, I know. I know,
>> right? Because I don't have the chain of
narration. I'm not throwing under the
bus. But what I am showing you is that
>> there's different narrations of the
story.
>> Uh I believe compilers and you've got
the references here. Iban Haban VC 6330
and from Imam Ahmed Imami
and Imam Muslim they all have a
consensus on the topic being by the
night when it envelops and not by the
creator as you've highlighted in the
Quran.
>> So I would need to do some more
scholarly work on this and come back to
you.
>> Yeah, that's fair.
>> But what I'm seeing is there's there's
five collectors. One is referring to the
topic, four are referring to the other
verse. M
>> it may be that they're actually talking
to God.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's interesting. Yeah. Um
that's interesting. Yeah, I definitely
love to see what you what else you say.
But yeah, my channel is God Logic
Apologetics. So my email or any of my
contacts if you have Instagram or
whatever, you can message me on
anything.
>> I'm on you. I use I don't use any of the
other.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So YouTube is for
free. Yeah, for sure.
>> Give the folks on your channel time to
speak as well.
>> I do.
>> You don't like what they have to say.
>> I do. Yousef. I talk just like this. You
You don't want to.
>> Come on,
>> dude. You gave me so much air time and
people phoning into your channel.
>> Uhhuh.
>> You You cut them off.
>> I only No, I only cut them off if
they're wasting if they're if they're
being dishonest. That's when I cut them
off.
>> That's
>> But I'm having a good conversation like
this and intellectual dialogue. They can
stay as long as they want
>> and and and that's all I'm encouraging.
>> If you're having a channel to engage
with Muslims,
>> afford them the opportunity to
>> I do you have a good day.
you.
>> Oh my god. Magic.
[Music]